visit the new york times website at
nytimes.com
and click on books
alexandra robbins tell me the story
behind secrets of the two
secrets of the tomb is an expose and an
analysis of probably the world's most
infamous secret society skull bones is
the society to which president george w
bush belongs it is also the society to
which senator john kerry belongs which
will make the presidential election of
2004 particularly interesting it'll be
the first bones versus bones ballot
are you a yellow yourself i am a yali i
graduated in 1998 i was a member of
another secret society however since
this book has been published i fear i
might not be a member anymore
what's the name of that one
the name of that secret society was
scroll and key which is also lumped with
skull and bones uh often however we
didn't have the death motif of skull and
bones we didn't have a tomb full of
skeletons and coffins and mummies and we
also don't follow the same agenda as
skull and bones which is basically to
get their members into positions of
power and then once those members are in
positions of power for them to hire
other members and and elevate their
stature which is something that bush has
done for members of skull and bones for
example who are some key people in the
administration who are skull and
bonesmen
one of george w bush's first
appointments was the assistant attorney
general of the justice department's
largest litigation component he's a
member of skull bones so is the general
counsel of the office of homeland
security bush's first choice for
secretary of defense was also a member
of skull bones frederick smith the ceo
of federal express but he had to
withdraw for health considerations
patronage is as old as the presidency so
why are you particularly interested or
concerned in this president of
appointing skull and bones people
i think a lot of people in america are
disturbed that a secret society can have
so much influence in the country it may
not be a coincidence that we have the
most secret government that we've seen
since the nixon era and that this secret
government full of
a super secret spy court and a shadow
government and leaders being whisked to
secret undisclosed locations i don't
think it's a coincidence that the
president is a member of the country's
most secret society if it's so secret
how are you able to tell the story
ah luck
i have been threatened by skull and
bones skull and bones
has made it known to me that it's angry
i was harassed they hung up on me but i
did manage to get more than 100 members
of skull and bones to speak with me and
i came across a sheath of documents that
revealed many of the secrets of the tomb
give me a for instance about some of the
revelations your readers will find in
the book sure
well i when i began this book i intended
to debunk many of the conspiracy
theories one surprise to me was that
many of the theories are based on
kernels of truth for example somebody
had had said to me that skull and bones
dropped the atom bomb i did not believe
it but i investigated it and it turns
out that henry stimpson the secretary of
war in world war ii uh was a member of
skull bones he hired other members of
skull and bones to work with him in the
war department he put those bonesmen in
charge of the deployment of the atomic
bomb so there are kernels of truth in
most every conspiracy theory about this
secret society
what should people know about your alma
mater that it fosters or allows these
kinds of organizations to exist a lot of
people ask me if these societies are so
terrible why does yale allow them to
insist while many members of the yale
administration are members of these
secret societies themselves is yale
alone in these kinds of societies
actually many schools especially ivy
league schools across america have
secret societies but skull and bones and
yale sacred societies have traditionally
stood very far apart and above the rest
i think it has something to do with the
the gothic elitism at yale tell me about
your writing career how did you become a
writer how did you get started in all
this
i started writing when i was 19 for a
very kind and generous editor at the
washington post
my first book was a book called quarter
life crisis which came out about a year
and a half ago
and then i decided to shift to something
a little more a little more serious and
to move my career in an investigative
journalism direction and that's what led
me to skull and bones are you writing
full-time books full-time and
are you making a living at it
i hope so i i write for magazines and
newspapers and i write books full time
now so we'll see how long i can keep it
going where's your home base washington
d.c
and what interests you next now that
you've done these two
i'm actually writing a third book now on
a secret organization however i'm
undercover this year so i'm not going to
tell you what the organization is
because that'll blow my case
well thank you for talking to us
alexander robin's book is called secrets
of the tomb skull and bones the ivy
league and the hidden paths of power
thank you
the men of the 23rd headquarters special
troops were recruited to become phantom
warriors in a ghost army for world war
ii